foreign
hey you guys back once again on another
installment of flickers of fear my movie
review Series so if you remember uh
quite recently I reviewed the latest
movie from Dario Argento 2022's dark
glasses and I think in that review I
talked a little bit about
you know kind of like how much uh I
loved Zario argento's early films and
sort of you know the quality you know
the decline in quality like in his
movies like they began like right around
the 1990s and uh continues pretty much
unabated to the present day I don't
think that's a very controversial
opinion to have uh I mean you know it's
a shame of course but you know it
happens to most artists as they age you
know he's in his 80s now and you know so
it's not just a problem that Dario
Argento in particular has a lot of
directors and other artistic people have
the same kind of thing happen so since
uh Suspiria from 1977 is one of my
favorite horror movies of all time and
since I'm also like a reasonably big fan
of the follow-up uh Inferno from 1980
nobody was more excited than I was back
in the mid 2000s when uh it started to
become clear that Dario Argenta was
finally going to finish his three
mothers Trilogy after all of this time
now the whole mythology surrounding the
three mothers which comes from Thomas
dequincy's Suspiria d profundus by the
way which is a book of like essays and
poems and stuff and the kind of like I
guess aesthetic Flair of the initial two
movies made me really eager to see what
a more modern take on the tale would
look like though I will admit that even
back then I knew that I was gonna have
to like temper my expectations somewhat
like I'd already seen the card player
from 2004 and that movie was not good so
you know but I still had high hopes that
Argento like going back to the Suspiria
well the witch well the three mothers
well I thought that he was gonna like
bring back the whole theme and make the
thing like of kind of like a visual
Feast like in line with the first two
movies in the trilogy so the third movie
mother of Tears uh only got released
into a handful of theaters I think it
was like seven theaters or some
ridiculous amount uh in at least in the
US in 2008 so I actually had to wait
back then until it was released on DVD I
think I don't I don't don't think I got
it until like 2009 so I ordered a copy
and like you know was kind of like
impatiently waiting for it to arrive so
I could see it so it finally arrived
back in 2009 or whatever uh you know I
popped it in the in the thing and uh
yeah well I okay
so like at the time I remember really
really not liking it and being so
disappointed that I mean not only did it
not really have any similarities or even
much continuity with the first two
movies like in the trilogy Suspiria or
Inferno but I kind of felt like it might
as well have not even been directed by
Dario Argento at all like because I was
like where's the style where's like the
operatic visuals where's the Grand
gignol like you know there was a lot of
Gore in mother of Tears which was cool
but there was no like Pizzazz you know
or that kind of like Dario Argento magic
like there was really none of that there
so honestly I don't think I've ever been
so disappointed in a movie as I was
about that one even after I had
specifically tried not to get my hopes
up too much so you know back then 2009
whenever it was it was a real bummer I'm
gonna say so then fast forward to 2022.
literally all I had remembered uh from
my experience of watching mother of
Tears first time was one how much I
thought it sucked and two having a vague
recollection of a woman getting impaled
through the cooch that's about all I
remembered about it so I was browsing
through Toby's horror selections uh the
other day and I noticed mother of Tears
scrolling by and I thought to myself uh
you know maybe it's time to revisit the
movie that broke my heart so miserably
back in 2009 just to see if maybe I'd
been too hard on it like all those years
ago I mean I do like to give movies
particularly if they've been made by
somebody that I'm really a big fan of
that I admire a lot
um I like to give them the benefit of a
second watch like just to make sure that
you know maybe the first time I watched
I was like in a bad mood or maybe I
didn't temper my expectations correctly
or something like that you know and
maybe that tainted my enjoyment of the
movie the first time it's been a long
time since I've seen it I couldn't
remember anything about it so I wanted
to like give it another go so I settled
in and I was kind of like genuinely
curious to see how this whole experiment
was gonna play out now I will say that
like for the first third of the film or
so I did actually think that maybe I had
been too unkind to Mother of Tears
initially like the first time that I saw
it I mean sure it wasn't a great movie
by any means but since I didn't go into
it with the expectation that it was
going to look like Suspiria or Inferno
or kind of like B of A theme with those
movies I already knew it wasn't going to
be like that so my expectations were a
little bit different
um so I could kind of like assess it on
its own merits instead of immediately
comparing it to those vastly Superior
movies so you know the first third of
the movie you know the setup is kind is
interesting like the opening Gore
sequences or like really really brutal
and actually really well done like some
good practical effects there uh the
score which is by Claudia Simonetti who
did like a bunch of his scores was
decent I mean it wasn't as good as his
earlier work but it was like still
pretty cool but then the whole thing
started to go downhill
and then I started to remember why I had
disliked the film so much back in 2009.
so by the time the quite ludicrous and
anti-climactic third act had rolled
around I was kind of like snickering and
like rolling my eyes and like shaking my
head I was just kind of like ruminating
on how far the mighty had fallen you
know what I mean like I'm not gonna sit
here and say that Mother of Tears is the
worst of Daria's later films I mean not
by a long shot I think most people would
probably agree that his worst movie is
Dracula 3D from 2012 I don't think
you're like I said again I don't think
that's at all a controversial opinion I
do think though that It suffers quite a
bit from kind of like a lazy messy uh
kind of overstuffed script some kind of
lackluster visuals uh very uneven acting
performances and I'm gonna say too like
an almost
spiteful refusal to take the mythology
and the legacy of the first two movies
seriously I think that was the thing
that made me the angriest about the
movie I mean there are some good
elements in here and in some ways I'm
gonna say uh you know re-watching this a
second time I liked it a little bit
better than you know the more recent
dark glasses just because mother of
Tears was more entertaining uh in
regards to like the stupidity of like
some of the choices that were made
whereas dark glasses was mostly just
kind of serviceable and like pedestrian
but overall I kind of found myself
disappointed in mother of Tears like all
over again only this time with all of
the added crankiness that you know the
Decker decade or so that's passed like
you know since I first saw it like with
that added on to it so at the beginning
of mother of Tears there's a
construction crew and they're working in
Viterbo cemetery and they Unearthed this
coffin that has like all these metal
crosses like stuck all over it and it's
also topped with like another smaller
coffee and which is just like a box they
call it like an urn
so the coffin that has the body in it is
actually like reburied but the urn like
the littler box with its it has like all
these unusual markings on the outside so
it gets sent to a museum in Rome like to
be studied now it's here that this
object crosses paths with the assistant
curator his name is Giselle is Giselle
and an art restoration student whose
name is Sarah Mandy who's played by Asia
Argento now these two women they just
can't wait to dig into this weird little
thing that they got sent and they stay
late at the Museum to see what's in
there so inside this urn there are three
ceramic figures like presumably
representing the three mothers I would
guess they are pretty cool they're like
little monster kind of things uh there's
a ceremonial dagger in there like with
skull and a jewel and [ __ ] on it and
this like red tunic type thing that has
like writing on it like that they can't
identify Giselle calls this a Talisman
but it's like a you know it's like a
piece of clothing
so after Giselle I think was it Giselle
or Sarah now I can't remember I just saw
this couple days ago but I can't
remember that little detail so after
either Giselle or Sarah like
conveniently cuts her finger and like
drips Blood on the box lid uh Sarah
actually leaves the room she's gonna go
get like some books from the library so
they can translate this whatever it is
that's like on this uh you know garment
and uh when she comes back though she
sees three hunched figures like and
they're absolutely annihilating Giselle
I mean the big pestle thing like they
stick it in her mouth so it like [ __ ]
her mouth all up and they like
disemboweling and it's just like the
whole [ __ ] ball of wax it's pretty
like it's pretty brutal also
um by the way there's a baboon for some
reason uh that chases Sarah and as also
as she's fleeing the museum she's kind
of initially she's trapped in there by
locked doors she's like kind of banging
on him like she can't get out but then
she hears this woman's voice in her head
like telling her to go and at that point
like all the doors like slam open by
themselves like in a very a paranormal
fashion now I will give points for this
scene for being like reasonably well
shot like intense and stuff having some
really [ __ ] up violence like I said
there was like some good practical
effects some good Gore in here this is a
very very violent film
and uh finally uh big props for finally
featuring a female character who
immediately takes off her high-heeled
shoes so she can run the [ __ ] away from
the danger instead of like staggering
around and then later taking them off I
mean that was like the first thing she
does she's like bye you know what I mean
so I was like points there yeah I like
that uh also the monkey is rad and
adorable and needs his or her own
spin-off so unsurprisingly when Sarah
tells the police what happened to
Giselle like mentioning the baboon and
the three Hunchback figures that she saw
she said she only saw him for a sec she
didn't say they were monsters or
anything she just said it was three
Hunchback figures like leaning over like
they could have been people but that
doesn't matter to the cops because in
these kind of movies like the police are
always portrayed as like these real like
incompetent [ __ ] like either one or
the other thing or both like the so the
officer is just kind of like smirk
condescendingly at her so they think
she's either crazy and or she's the
person that killed Giselle now they do
allow her to leave though uh at which
point she goes to the house of the
museum curator who is also her boyfriend
whose name is Michael he's played by
Adam James he's like a British actor and
I've seen him in a bunch of other things
but I can't remember what he's been on
like a bunch of British TV that's for
sure and he's been in some movies too
but I can't remember I've seen him
before so she tells him like about the
weird voice that she heard that pretty
much saved her life now Michael he's
kind of more of a believer in the
Supernatural like whereas Sarah is very
very skeptical so she is actually kind
of more on like I think I might be
losing my mind kind of end of the
spectrum and he's kind of like oh yeah
but maybe something like really weird
and paranormal is going on so meanwhile
while there's kind of like a Spate of
escalating savagery occurring like all
around Rome like there's guys tussling
in the streets and like wrecking cars
with bats there's two dudes like
shooting a cop there's a scene where a
woman takes her baby like out of the
stroller and like tosses the baby over a
bridge and it like smacks into the
abutment like on the way down and then
like falls in the water I mean it's a
pretty shocking because he was I was
like God damn you know what I mean I
mean that could only be from an Italian
movie there's no way like an American
filmmaker would put it that in a movie
um but yeah the Italians totally will
because they absolutely do not give a
[ __ ] so amidst all of this unfolding
chaos Michael is gets interested in like
the urn and the contents and whether it
was connected somehow to like giselle's
murder so he actually goes to Viterbo
like where the cemetery was like to talk
to the Monsignor like the guy that
oversaw the original find of the urn but
it turns out that the Monsignor had a
stroke like not too long after the urn
was discovered word and he can't talk
anymore so all he can do is basically
like pass Michael a piece of paper that
has the words modern La cremarum written
on it which the other priests basically
think is like meaningless nonsense like
they know what it means because it's
Latin it means like the mother of tears
but they know that but they're just like
whatever he's crazy he had a stroke so
Sarah on the other hand is doing her own
investigation over here and she happens
to meet this woman who knew her mother
whose name was Elisa now Elisa is played
by Asia argento's real life mother and
long time Dario Argento collaborator
Daria nicoloti now Elisa the mom
supposedly died in a car crash when
Sarah was a kid but this woman who's
she's talking to his name is Marta tells
her that Elisa was actually not killed
in a car crash but that she was actually
this really powerful white witch who was
murdered by Moder suspirium like during
a witch fight like back in the day
so during this whole sequence there's
like another helpful individual who's
there Padre Johannes who's actually
played by the inimitable Udo kir uh he
mentions that modern suspiri arm was
finally defeated by a dance student
named Susie Banyan which was a nice call
back to Suspiria and udokir was also in
Suspiria as well like playing a kind of
a similar like expositional role but
he's not at all like the same character
as he is here so Sarah starts to realize
that the voices she's been hearing and
all the weird like Supernatural help
that she's been receiving are pretty
likely like from her dead mother and
then she further realizes that she
probably has the same Powers though of
course they're underdeveloped because
she didn't acknowledge them before now
early on in the movie though um she is
able to elude capture like by the cops
by basically like standing in the corner
of like a library or bookstore or
something and willing herself to be like
invisible to onlookers so there's that
so Sarah's paranormal gifts get
confirmed not too long after that when
she starts to see The Apparition version
of her mother like appearing to her and
telling her to do things
now I will say it was nice to see Daria
nicoloti again but I kind of wish like
the ghost effects in here weren't so
damn cheesy looking and
um I do wish that the dialogue that she
was given wasn't so like real flimsy and
very very repetitive you know what I
mean it kind of got really old so anyway
through all of this brouhaha like it's
established that Giselle opening and
bleeding on the urn woke up the youngest
and cruelest of the three mothers the
powerful witch modern Locker marum the
mother of Tears obviously so her whole
stick is causing like Madness
pandemonium and despair uh hence the
admittedly kind of low-key crime wave
that's happening around Rome her
Awakening has also drawn the attention
of all the other evil witches in the
world who start to flock to Rome causing
like they're kind of hoping to cause
what the media starts calling like the
second fall of Rome now when I mentioned
earlier about this movie not taking the
mythology all that seriously this aspect
of the plot right here like with the
witch Gathering that's one of the main
things that I'm talking about at one
stage Sarah sees a gaggle of these
arriving witches like at a train station
I think it's a train station and they
look like it just basically looks like a
gang of these really loud obnoxious
Lucky Star era Madonna cosplayers
basically and they're just like whooping
and hollering like sorority girls at a
bachelorette party and they're just kind
of like shoving people out of their way
like bullies in an 80s John Hughes movie
it's like I almost expect him to go like
nerds you know what I mean it kind of
like came across like that like they're
not frightening they're not Sinister in
any way and I'm really kind of like
mystified as to why Dario Argento like
chose to portray them that way because
they don't like seem like they pose a
threat at all I mean other than to the
eardrums of people that are like closest
to them because they're constantly like
whooping and yelling
um now I would I did enjoy the one
sequence where there was one witch who
was chasing Sarah like onto a train and
she kind of like Falls and then like
Sarah like smooshes her head like in
this sliding bathroom door like I
thought that was like pretty funny but
that's kind of like emblematic of what I
mean though like just how terrifying and
Powerful can a witch be when you can
basically just like slam her head in the
door of the nearest [ __ ] and like
make her eyeball pop out you know what I
mean it's like that does she doesn't
seem like she's posing any threat you
know so anyway like various other things
happen like both the witches and the
cops are pursuing Sarah while her ghost
mom keeps like popping out and like
telling her what to do Michael's son
gets uh abducted and killed presumably
by The Witches though this isn't shown
even though the movie is absolutely not
shy about showing little kids getting
killed otherwise Michael I think also
gets killed off screen but then comes
back as like kind of a zombie type of
situation before disappearing from the
film altogether
um Udo Kier later gets his face turned
into hamburger with a Cleaver so that's
nice uh Marta and her girlfriend get
horribly brutally murdered Marta by
having her a spear like shoved up her
badge which was like I said the only
scene that I remembered like from the
first time that I watched it uh there's
a scene where a mom eats her little boy
so there's that and then at last there
is the big confrontation between Sarah
and modern locker maram and the witch
coven down in these like catacombs but I
have to say it's literally one of the
lamest like final battles in cinema
history basically all Sarah has to do to
defeat the witch is pull off her Magic
Flash Dance tunic with a spear and she
dies you know what I mean she's just
like I'm defeating I'm mounting I'm
mounting you know what I mean it's just
kind of it's that kind of a thing and
like at least like throwing water on the
witch I mean that seemed a little lame
too but you know what I mean it's just I
don't know it's just I can't I can't I
really don't understand here's the thing
I don't really understand like why so
much time was invested on Sarah
developing her white witchcraft Powers
if she wasn't gonna fight the mother of
tears at the end with you know
witchcraft I mean I thought that that's
what it was building up to I mean is it
implied that she was like the only
person who could have bested the witch
by literally just taking her top off
because that's basically what she did or
could anyone have done that at any time
and like I said you know that means the
witch isn't all that powerful you know
what I mean I'll note too that the few
times that we see the mother of Tears
like prior to this last confrontation
she actually isn't wearing the tunic
she's actually wearing this black sheer
hooded robe thing like with one boob
exposed I think it's on some of the
posters and like the DVD cover art
um oh there are lots and lots and lots
of boobs in this movie by the way I mean
not that I'm complaining they're all
nice boobs and everything but I mean so
if you like looking at boobs like and
really nice boobs and stuff like that
then that's you know a point in the
movie's favor because there are a lot of
boobs in it so after the Witch and all
her followers perish basically um having
staged evidently the only attempted
satanic World takeover that hinged
solely on a single person wearing a
shirt
I just can't I can't get past that I
can't
um so
weapons like Sarah and one of the cops
Enzo who had actually been hostile to it
had been chasing her before this but I
guess now that he saw the witch [ __ ]
like he believes her but he was barely
in the movie otherwise so I'm not really
sure why he gets to be like the adjunct
final girl you would have thought that
it would have been her boyfriend but
whatever
um so they climbed through this you know
admittedly like pretty yucky and gross
looking like series of tunnels like in
the catacombs that have like all these
dead bodies and this lumpy corpse juice
um you know so that's pretty gross and
then they climb out of like a manhole
and into the morning or whatever it into
what is very very clearly a green
screened city backdrop I mean it's very
very bad green screen so then they like
sit there in the street and just like
laugh hysterically and then the credits
roll and I'm like all right so okay
that's how you want to end your movie
all right all right now I mean okay I
know that it sounds like I'm completely
[ __ ] all over the movie here and I I
mean I kind of am I admit that but as I
mentioned it does have some good things
about it um The Kills and the gore are
great I mean they're really violent very
creative very [ __ ] up especially the
stuff involving like babies and kids but
people get killed in like really gross
like creative ways which is nice the
First Act of the movie well it's not
amazing or anything like that but it's
pretty engaging like it gets you
interested in this escalating mystery
like I like witches and I like kind of
that whole you know mythological kind of
like aspect to it so that part is good
but then it just all starts falling
apart like the witches are not
intimidating or scary at all they just
kind of seem like a bunch of silly like
cackling teenagers like trying to look
like edgy mid-2000 scene kids you know
what I mean uh the special effects
having to do with Sarah's mom look
pretty cheesy like pretty cheap and to
be honest like ghost mom doesn't really
have all that much meaningful
information to give even when she does
show up
um there's even a scene where the mom
like tells Sarah I don't have any more
time I can't talk to you again but then
literally like the next scene she pops
back in and like tells her [ __ ] like she
never even said that last thing I'm just
like okay whatever
um there was also like the whole final
battle that I alluded to earlier which
was resolved like way too easily
especially after all this build up about
Sarah kind of finding out the truth
about her mom and about her own
Supernatural powers and all that stuff
and I'm gonna say too that like while
the cinematography here is fine it isn't
anything special it doesn't have any of
the kind of like surreal nightmarish
like super color saturated like glamor
and that stylish kind of look to it like
the first two films did which made them
just like this beautiful eye candy I
mean the movie it basically looks like
it could have been directed and shot by
anyone I think the cinematography on
here was not the one that he used to
work with like back in the day I think
it was the same guy that shot do you
like Hitchcock which was one of his like
TV movies so it looks very workman-like
it looks very pedestrian it doesn't look
like anything like Fantastical also I
mean the acting isn't that all that
great like across the board I mean
several characters are like overreacting
or under reacting I mean I seen Asia
Argento in particular like do some good
acting work but she's kind of like
uneven here I feel like I feel like in
some scenes she's decent and then like
in other ones she comes across as like
very awkward or just like not good so I
mean I think the concept and like the
story of the movie is a good concept and
it would have been like a good follow-up
I think it's just like the execution of
it that's lacking that really like lets
it down personally if it was me and I
realize I'm not making this movie but
I'm just saying personally if it was me
I would have dropped the whole witch
Gathering subplot and just made it so
that modern lock or marum herself was
the one like causing all the destruction
because I think that would have made her
seem like much more powerful much more
villainous you know what I mean like she
was like the biggest threat because it
was just her like she didn't need all
these you know cackling minions uh I
would have also had her not talk uh she
doesn't talk all that much in the movie
but I think that like really undercut
her scariness which she wasn't very
scary to start with
um I would have kept her more in the
shadows she could still be sexy and
beautiful like she was in the movie
movie and honestly like for the original
like Thomas DeQuincy like levana and Our
Lady of Sorrows that is how modern
Locker maram is described like as very
very young and beautiful so that totally
tracks like with the original Source
material so you could have her be sexy
and beautiful but I think that she
should have been like I would have made
her much creepier and like more
threatening and not shown her as much
and like I said not have her talking
like make her more mysterious I didn't
actually mind like the whole revelation
of Sarah's white witch powers because it
kind of had a thing where it was like
witch versus witch I like that but I
think I would have just like abandoned
the whole mom Apparition angle maybe
just have her mom like communicate her
like in with in some other way like you
know it could even be a supernatural way
like through a medium or through some
other kind of like ghostly messages like
she leaves messages or something like
that I think that would have worked out
better so you didn't have that cheesy
ghost effect
um also obviously I would have beefed up
the big face off like between Sarah and
the mother of tears at the end making it
revolve more around magic and less
around you know a simple disrobing which
you know was admittedly a little wah wah
you know what I mean it was just kind of
like that but you know those are just
some meaningless suggestions from some
random horror lover on the internet so
you know feel free to please disregard
any of these ideas so that will do it
for this flickers of fear have you seen
mother of Tears what did you think about
it what is your favorite Dario Argento
movie please tell me down in the
comments and I'll see you guys again on
the next one bye